foreign
military milestone for the ukrainians if
in fact it happens that Russia follows
through and withdraws to the far side of
the danipa river of course we're going
to watch actions and not just
announcements to see what what actually
unfolds
we do see some indications of movement
consistent with what the announcements
were yesterday but this is an involved
operation the Russians had flowed a
significant number of forces and
Personnel into curacaan City and to the
west side of the danipa river so it's
not the kind of thing you just snap your
fingers and it's done
uh but of course it's not the end of the
war because Russia continues to occupy
uh parts of Ukrainian territory We are
continuing to support the ukrainians in
their effort to defend their sovereignty
and territorial integrity and as the
president said yesterday we're Guided by
a very simple principle nothing about
Ukraine without Ukraine it is ultimately
up to Ukraine to make determinations
about its diplomatic course it is our
job to put them in the best position on
the battlefield so that when and if
there is an opportunity for diplomacy
they're in the best position at the
bargaining table the United States is
not pressuring Ukraine we're not
insisting on things with Ukraine what we
are doing is Consulting as partners and
showing our support not just through
public statements or moral support but
through the tangible physical support of
the kind of military assistance I
mentioned before we have to see the real
movement of the uh units or their
platoons in hersson District and
according to our intelligence data they
didn't
started their real movement and for
example from the Hearthstone and we see
them still in city and around the city
and in the Western Bank of the ipro
river as well
and we know that they have the
all kind of their military groups
approximately four thousand forty five
thousand uh personnel
in Harrison District it's a lot of it's
a huge quantity of the Personnel so just
just imagine 40
000 people with the equipment Weaponry
uh armed Vehicles tanks etc etc so it
can it's not the easy to withdraw these
troops from the Hearthstone during one
day or two days
as minimum one week is
no significant indications to say that
this would be a trap of any operational
or strategic significance uh just I
think Russia is actually not that clever
at the moment in terms of what they can
do in their military operations however
tactically I mean the city is likely to
be laced with improvised explosive
devices and it'll take a significant
amount of time for the ukrainians to
clear roots in and out of the city but
also clear the buildings and I suppose
Russia would have tried to do that to
further degrade Ukrainian forces but
ensure that Ukrainian forces can't
quickly follow up uh they're advancing
to Kirsten City itself